Hey, gang!
Did you know you can
send notifications
to iOS devices using
Google Cloud Messaging?
Well, you can.
Why would you ever
want to do that?
Maybe that's a better question.
Let's find out the answer
on this episode of Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So notifications, they
are a great way for you
to engage with your users.
They let your customers know you
have important, new information
for them.
And when used responsibly,
they can be a great way
to keep users coming
back to your app.
But they're not super
fun to implement.
There's a lot of steps required
to set up notifications
in the first place.
You need logic on both
the client and the server.
And if you're developing a
cross-platform mobile app--
and most of you are
these days-- you
have to do this for
Android and for iOS.
And I'm not just talking
about two sets of client logic
either.
It turns out sending
notifications to iOS
and Android devices requires
different logic on the server,
too.
See if you've done any
notifications work in the past,
you're probably used to talking
to APNS-- that's the Apple Push
Notification Service--
to deliver notifications
to iOS devices and
to GCM-- that's
Google Cloud Messaging--
to deliver notifications
to Android devices.
And while sending notifications
through these two services
is similar, they each have
slightly different features,
use different protocols, accept
different message payloads,
and return different
responses, all of which
means that you've got to keep
track of what kind of device
each of your users has and use
two completely different code
paths to send a notification.
Or do you?
Well, no.
No, you don't.
You see one pretty great feature
about Google Cloud Messaging
that a lot of people
don't know about
is that GCM can relay to
APNS any notifications you
want to send to an iOS device.
Now granted, you'll need to do
some setup work, like upload
your APNS certificate
to GCM and make
sure your client sends its
device token to the GCM
service.
But once you've
done that, you can
use GCM to send all
of your notifications
no matter what platform
your target device is.
And GCM will deliver
your notifications
to the correct device using
the appropriate service.
Well, this means
that you don't need
to care about what device
your user has anymore.
You just have to write and
maintain one code path.
And as we all know, less code
means less room for mistakes.
But it's not just
about using less code.
By using GCM to handle
your messaging for you,
you can take advantage of some
of the other nice features
that GCM offers to
developers, like topics.
Topics allow your app to
subscribe to notifications
about any particular topic
that you or your users want to.
For example, let's say
you've got a weather app.
And I, as a loyal
weather fan, want
to be notified whenever there's
extreme weather happening
in my zip code.
Well, in the old
way of doing this,
you'd probably need to
set up a database where
you keep track of
each one of your users
and their devices
and their zip codes
and do this whole select users
where blah, blah, blah, query.
Then, loop through the
results and send notifications
to each device that you get
back from this database query.
But with topics, none
of that's necessary.
Instead, your app
simply tells GCM
that you're interested
in subscribing to, say,
the WEATHER_94043 topic.
Then, next time there's
rain in California--
for us that counts
as extreme weather--
Oh my gosh!
There's something coming
down from the sky.
I don't know if it's
water or if it's acid.
I can't go out.
I don't know how
to drive anymore.
Yeah, that seems about right.
So, yeah, with topics,
your server simply
tells GCM to send notifications
to all devices subscribed
to the WEATHER_94043 topic.
And I will get notified
along with all other devices
subscribed to that topic.
So there's no database required.
Go ahead and throw it out.
Oh, as long as you weren't using
it for anything else, I guess.
I probably should have
mentioned that earlier.
GCM has other useful
features, too,
like upstream messaging, which
allows your app to communicate
to your server through GCM.
This can be helpful
in cases where
you might want some lightweight
communication from your clients
to your server, but
don't feel like dealing
with the hassle of
setting up and maintaining
a full blown server open
to the entire world.
Or read receipts, where in
some, but not all situations,
you can be notified
that a user has received
your message, something
you can't normally
do through APNS alone.
Oh, and in case
you're wondering,
all this is free, as
in please send us $0.
And it's using much of
the same infrastructure
that Google uses
for its own apps.
So it'll probably
scale for yours.
So there's a lot to learn when
it comes to notifications,
and I encourage you
to get started here
with our Google Cloud Messaging
Documentation for iOS.
We also have a couple of
sample applications for you
to look at.
There's Friendly Ping, our
cross-platform chat app powered
entirely through
Google Cloud Messaging,
as well as the
GCMPlayground, which
lets you easily experiment
with sending calls
through the GCM service.
And keep watching Route 85.
Maybe you'll see another
Google Cloud Messaging
video pop up in the future.
If only we had some
way of letting you
know when that happened.
Well, I'm stumped.
[MUSIC PLAYING]